welcome to the video on completing the
square what's completing the square well
it's a way to solve a quadratic equation
and so before i actually let me just
write down a quadratic equation and then
i will show you how to complete the
square and then we'll do another example
and then maybe we'll talk a little bit
about
why it's called completing the square so
let's say i have
this equation
x squared
plus
x
minus 57
is equal to 0. so what are the
what are the tools in our toolkit right
now that we could use to solve this well
we could try to factor it out we could
say you know what two numbers add up to
16 and when you multiply them they're
minus 57 and you'd have to think about
it a little bit and you might get whole
numbers but you're not even sure if
there are two whole numbers that work
out like that this problem there are but
you know sometimes the solution is a is
a decimal number and you don't know it
so the only time you can really factor
is if you're sure
that
that you could factor this into kind of
integer expressions you know x plus some
integer x minus some integer times you
know x plus some other integer or
likewise your other option is to do the
quadratic equation and what we're going
to see is actually the quadratic
equation is just
essentially a shortcut to completing the
square the quadratic equation is
actually proven
using completing the square so what is
completing the square
so what do we do
let's well before we we move into this
video let's see what a what happens if i
square an expression what is
let me do it in this down here
what is x
plus
a
squared
well that equals
x squared plus 2a
plus
sorry 2ax
a squared right so if you ever see
something in this form you know that
it's something it's x plus something
squared
so wouldn't it be neat if we could
manipulate this equation so we can write
it as you know x plus a squared equals
something and then we can just take the
square root and what we're going to do
is actually do just that and that is
completing the square so let's let's let
me show you an example i think an
example will make it a little clearer
let me box this away this is what you
need to remember this is the whole
rationale behind completing the squares
to get an equation into this form onto
one hand one side of the equation just
have a number on the other side so you
can take the square root of both sides
so let's see first of all this let's
just check to make sure this isn't a
perfect square if this were let's see
this coefficient would be equivalent to
the 2a
right so a would be 8 and then this
would be 64.
this is clearly not 64. so this right
here is not a squared expression
so what can we do well let's let me get
rid of the 57 by adding 57 to both sides
of this equation so i would get
x squared
plus
16x
is equal to
57 all i did is i added 57 to both sides
of this equation
now what could i add here so that this
the left-hand side of this equation
becomes a square becomes a square of you
know some expression like x plus a
well i have
if you if you just follow this pattern
down here we have x squared
plus 2 a x so you could view this let me
see you could view this right here
as 2
ax
right
that's 2ax
and then we need to add an a squared to
it right plus
a squared and then we would have the
form here but we know from basic algebra
that anything you do to one side of an
equation you have to do another so we
added an a squared here so let's add an
a squared
here as well
and now we could
take you could essentially rewrite this
as a square of some expression but
before that we have to figure out what a
was well how do we do that
well what was what is a if this
expression right here is 2ax what is a
well 2a is going to equal 16. so a is
equal to eight and you could you could
solve you could usually do that just by
inspection do it in your head but if you
wanted to see it done algebraically you
could actually write 2 a x is equal to
16 x
and then divide both sides by 2x and you
get a is equal to 16x over 2x and
assuming that x doesn't equal 0 this
evaluates to a
to 8 sorry
so a is 8. so if a is 8 we could rewrite
that expression i'll switch colors
arbitrarily as
x squared
plus
16 x
plus a squared well 64
because a is 8
is equal to 57
plus
64.
right all we did i i went through
a fairly tedious explanation here but
all we've really done to get from there
to there
is we added 57 to both sides of this
equation to kind of get it on the right
hand side and then we added 64 to both
sides of this equation and why did i add
64 to both sides of this equation so
that the left-hand side expression takes
this form
now that the left-hand side expression
takes this form i can rewrite it as
what
x plus a squared i can rewrite it in
this form and we know that a is 8 so it
becomes x
plus
squared is equal to and what's 57 plus
64 let's see 11 plus
it's 121.
now we have what looks like a fairly
straightforward
it's still a quadratic equation actually
because if you expand this side you get
a quadratic but we can solve this
without using the quadratic equation
without having to factor we can just
take the square root of both sides of
this if we take the square root of both
sides what do we get
we get our once again arbitrarily
switching colors that x
plus 8 is equal to and remember this the
plus or minus square root of 121
and what's the square root of 121 what's
11 right
so there we come here let me box this
away so you know this was just an aside
so we get x
plus
8 is equal to plus or minus 11.
and so x is equal to subtract 8 from
both sides minus 8 plus or minus 11
and so
x could equal
so minus 8
plus 11
is 3
right
minus 8
plus 11. let me make sure i did that
right
right x
x is equal to minus 8
plus or minus 11
yes that's right
so
x could be equal to 3
and then if i took minus 8 minus 11
x could also equal or
x could equal minus
19.
right and let's see if that makes sense
so in theory
this should be able to be factored as
x minus 3 times x plus 19
is equal to 0 right because these are
the two solutions of this equation and
that works out right 3 ti not minus 3
times 19 is minus 57
and minus 3
plus 19 is plus 16x so if
we could have just immediately factored
it this way but if that wasn't obvious
to us because these are at least 19 is
kind of a strange number we could do it
completing the square
so let's do another example and so why
is it called completing the square
because you get in this form then you
have to add the 64 here to kind of
complete the square to turn this left
hand expression into a squared
expression
let's do one more and i won't i'll do
less explanation and more just chugging
through the problem and that actually
might make it seem simpler
but this is going to be a hairier
problem
so let's say i have
x
squared minus
7x
minus 3 is equal to 0.
you could try to factor it but
personally
i don't enjoy factoring things when i
have a coefficient here and you say oh
why don't we divide both sides of this
equation by 6. but then you'd get a
fraction here and a fraction here and
that's even worse to factor just by
inspection you could do the quadratic
equation and and maybe i'll show you in
a future video the quadratic equation
and i think i've already done one where
i proved the quadratic equation but the
quadratic equation is essentially
completing the square it's kind of a
shortcut it's just kind of remembering
the formula
but let's complete the square here
because that's what the point of this
video was
so
let's add the 3 to both sides of that
equation we could do well let's add the
3 first so we get
6 x squared minus 7 x
is equal to
i added 3 to both sides
and some teachers will leave the minus
three here and then try to figure out
what to add to it and all that but i
like to get it out of the way so that i
can figure out very cleanly what number
i should put here
but i also don't like this six here it
just complicates things i like something
you know x i like to have it x plus a
squared not you know some square root in
front of coefficient on the x term so
let's divide both sides of this equation
by 6
and you get
x squared
minus 7 6
x
is equal to
3 divided by 6 is equal to 1 half
and we could have made that our first
step we could have divided by 6 right at
that first step
anyway now let's try to complete the
square so we have x squared i'm just
going to open up some space minus 7 6
x
plus something is going to be equal to
one half
and so we have to add something here so
that this left hand expression becomes a
squared expression so how do we do that
well essentially we take
we look at this coefficient and keep in
mind it's not just 7 6. it's minus 7 6.
you take half of it and then you square
it
right just remember x let me do it you
know x plus a
squared is equal to x squared plus 2 a x
plus a squared right this is what you
have to remember all the time that's all
completing the square is based off of
so why did what did i say just now well
this term is going to be half of this
coefficient squared and how do we know
that because a
is going to be half of this coefficient
if you just do a little bit of pattern
matching
so what's half of this coefficient
half of 7 6 half of minus 7 6 is minus 7
12.
so we could if you want you could write
a equals minus 7 12 for our example
and i just multiplied this by one half
right
so what do i add to both sides i add a
squared
so what's 7 12 squared
what's going to be 49
over 144
if i did it to the left-hand side i have
to do it to the right-hand side
plus 49
over 144
and now what
what how can i simplify this left-hand
side what's our next step well we now
know it is a perfect square in fact we
know what a is a is minus 7 12. and so
we know that this left hand side of this
equation
is
x minus a
or x plus a but a is a negative number
so x plus a
and a is negative
squared and if you want you can multiply
this out and confirm that it truly
equals this
and that is going to be equal to
let's get a common denominator 144.
so 72
plus 49 it equals what's that 121.
121 over 144. so we have x minus 7 12
all of that squared is equal to 121
over 144
so what do we do now well now we just
take the square root of both sides of
this equation and we get and i'm trying
to free up some space
switch to green
let me partition this off
and we get
x
minus 7 12
is equal to this plus or minus square to
that so plus or minus
over 12 right square root of 121 is 11
square root of 144 is 12.
so then we can add 7 12 to both sides of
this equation and we get x
is equal to
over 12
plus or minus 11 over 12. well that's
the same thing as that equals 7 plus or
minus 11 over 12. so what are the two
options
7 plus 11 is 18 over 12. so x could
equal 18 over 12 is three halves
or what's seven minus eleven
that's minus four twelve so it's minus
one third
there you have it
that is completing the square hopefully
you found that reasonably insightful and
if you want to prove the quadratic
equation all you have to do is instead
of having numbers here
write a x squared plus bx plus c equals
0 and then complete the square using
those those the a b's and c's instead of
numbers and you will end up with the
quadratic equation by this point and i
think i did that in a video let me know
if i didn't then i'll do it for you
anyway i'll see you in the next video